this ship is on a collision course can I
show you something I think you should
all see come with me and the Oh buddy's
forgotten where as live for guests to
stay in this hotel then April how much
is this room $250 a night Friday and
Saturday is $180 the rest of the week
let me show you what $250 gets you at
the Monticello hotel the light so you
see that this plate light shows up
bodily fluids that's exactly what you're
saying I wouldn't want to lay on that
bed where these mattresses come from
pollute the house in Arizona your house
yes wow those two holes there that's
cigarette holes burns shoes I was
totally grossed out when I seen that bed
it was sickening two hundred and fifty
dollars to sleep in filth oh my god so
it's semen right there is everywhere
does that make anybody else feel sick
yes right now I am [ __ ] disgusted by
this bowel polluted bed
I felt dirty I'm a clean person was
disgusting
I don't know why you're running a hotel
she's just ripping people off we don't
care for the customers you don't care
for your staff could you care for I care
about missed out the first thing you
said to me when I arrived here Philip
what's the problem
staff they're bleeding the clock no way
that's what you told me I've got half it
Wroten down at home where I put at least
a hundred hours free in here we will
come in an hour two hours early not
punching in and then we will work late
to get what we need to get done you have
an estate to the tune of ten [ __ ]
million dollars and a chef that was a
hundred hours in for nothing
what was he lying
hey Cyril's 9 I'm suppose you guys are
here I'm the only owner for my family
and I make 500 bucks every two weeks
this is [ __ ] crazy
and you rock up here with a plate with
hotel help how the [ __ ] is going on
these guys are your bread and butter
your [ __ ] backbone but they're
terrified to tell you the truth shall
keep on cutting corners and humiliating
them because they're the problem the
fact those not busy look within it
starts from the [ __ ] top amen yeah
just excuse me leaving here on my own
with fellow thank you
now can you [ __ ] your man up I don't
have all the answers Gordon I'm trying
give me one [ __ ] answer give me
something you're abusing your staff what
kind of message does it send to them
when you fill the car park with classic
cars and they're [ __ ] struggling jig
is fair I think it's fair enough no they
deserve better of course
y-you do you I don't have an answer for
that I don't know why I'm doing that gal
for me leave me alone get the [ __ ] out
[Music]